un bon jour l'une des clés pour
comprendre la crise que nous traversons
en particulier sa dimension politique
c'est ce que vous appelez le syndrome du
sang contaminé
oui il me semble depuis le début et
j'observe certains comportements et à
certaines décisions que effectivement un
souvenir hante nos dirigeants en
particulier le premier ministre et les
ministres pas le président parce que
vous savez qu'il est responsable
pénalement pendant pendant son mandat
mais c'est ce que j'appelle le syndrome
du sang contaminé vous vous souvenez
bien sûr de laurent fabius et de deux
autres ministres d'ailleurs mise de la
santé qui avait été attaqué en justice
et qui était passé devant la cour de
justice de la république si je me
souviens bien et ça avait parce que on
avait on les avait accusés d'avoir
transmis des lots de sang contaminé par
le sida et on vous souvenez que saad et
briser la carrière politique et le
destin de laurent fabius
est ce que cette crainte explique la
colère que l'on ressent chez certains
maires chez un grand nombre d'entre eux
mêmes contre l'état alors je pense que
ça explique le comportement hyper
prudent d'edouard philippe ça explique
les auto justification permanente de
olivier ferrand et même de jérôme
salomon tous les soirs et effectivement
je pense que ça explique aussi les
comportements le comportement des mères
depuis que le confinement était quand
même décidé déconfinement confiné mais
mais quand même et qui les maires ont
terriblement peur eux ils ont l'habitude
ils ont l'habitude de cette
judiciarisation depuis 20 ans
malgré la loi fauchon je crois en 2000
qui avait réduit un peu cavayé qui
allait limiter un peu les possibilités
de les délester de les données de les
attaquer en justice
il n'empêche qu'ils connaissent ça ils
en ont peur ils savent que ça peut être
redoutable
et donc il si vous voulez il demande à
l'état de ne pas prendre des décisions
pour eux parce que ce sont eux qui
seront en première ligne judiciaire les
maires demandent une loi pour limiter
leur responsabilité limitée le risque de
poursuites judiciaires
comment se seraient ressenties à votre
avis par l'opinion comme une forme
d'auto amnistie alors c'est c'est tout
le set où la problématique de cette
histoire effectivement vous avez raison
et d'autant plus que vous avez vu leurs
bergers la porte parole du groupe peu en
marche a étendu sa à toutes les
personnes chargées de politiques
publiques
évidemment derrière vous voyez on
revient à mon histoire de sang contaminé
évidemment qu'on veut autoamnistié
également le premier ministre et les
ministres
en tout cas c'est comme ça que ça sera
prix vous avez raison j'ai bien
conscience de 2 si vous voulez de marché
sur un sur un fil entre deux écueils
le premier écueil je suis d'accord que
les gouvernants doivent être
responsables de leurs politiques de
leurs décisions contradictoires de leur
retard à l'allumage
voyez tout ce qui s'est passé au début
et que j'ai moi même critiqué et en même
temps je pense et c'est l'autre écueil
je pense que ce n'est pas le juge qui
doit diriger et qui doit juger les
politiques c'est le peuple en démocratie
c'est le peuple qui est souverain et non
pas le juge je reconnais que c'est
une situation très délicate mais je m'en
tiens à cette ligne la plus on donne de
pouvoir au juge plus ça se retourne
finalement contre le peuple qui croit au
début qui est content au début que le
juge sanctionne les politiques en fait
cette peur de la justice
est ce que c'est une manifestation
supplémentaire d'une réalité que vous
dénoncez depuis longtemps le
gouvernement des juges
si vous voulez cesser je vois bien dans
un premier réflexe on va dire il est
tout à fait normal que les politiques
soient responsables de leurs actes et on
va critiquer on va condamner leurs
tentatives de d'échapper aux juges
enfin c'est notre premier réflexe je
pense qu'il faut faire attention à ce
réflexe vous savez si je me permettais
une comparaison historique c'est comme
ça que la monarchie a été détruite tous
les gens poussaient les parlements à à
contester le pouvoir du roi et ça a fini
par la révolution
je pense que il ne faut pas oublier nos
principes il ne faut pas donner trop de
pouvoirs aux juges même si ça nous fait
plaisir si j'ose dire
dans un premier temps merci eric zemmour